by the end of 2021 cyber crime is
expected to cost the world 6 trillion us
dollars by 2025 this figure will climb
to 10.5 trillion dollars
the global information security market
is forecasted to grow to
170.4 billion dollars in 2022 to go to
the rising cyber crime projection
india alone will be shot by about 3.5
million cyber security analysts
what does this mean for your career
an excellent opportunity for those who
want to specialize in this area and seek
jobs
both within india and globally
with this in mind we have developed an
all-encompassing cyber security program
that can propel you to be an expert
with the associated skills and
credentials in this very important and
exciting field
welcome to the advanced executive
program in cyber security in
collaboration with triple i t bangalore
and the national payment corporation of
india npci
triple it bangalore with proven academic
excellence
and npci the organization behind the
ubiquitous
digital payment solutions such as the
unified payment interface upi
bharat interface for money bim
immediate payment services imps
and simply learn the world leader in
continuing professional education
have come together to offer you a
program
to fulfill the market demands on cyber
security
master the most in demand skills
defensive cyber security
application security
malware and ransomware analysis
ethical hacking
and much more in a cutting edge
curriculum designed by top academia and
industry experts
with live classes from top cyber
security practitioners themselves
learn by doing
practice
30 plus demos and multiple projects on
integrated labs alongside professionals
from around the world in an atex higher
live interaction global boot camp
attend master classes from triple i t
bangalore faculty and validate your
learning with a triple iet bangalore
program transcript
the program culminates with a virtual
internship
where experts from npci will conduct
sessions specifically on cyber security
issues
in the digital payment industry
upon successful completion of this part
of the program you will also receive a
virtual internship certificate from nvci
at the end of it all march out to the
career you have deserved all along
with your triple i t bangalore advanced
executive program in cyber security
certificate
getting you closer to that niche job
that you always wanted come
meet us at our next
apply now